in this video we're going to talk about
energy conservation or trying to save or
lower the amount of energy that we use
now a lot of y'all might already have a
sense that that is a good thing while
others of you might say hey why can't i
just use as much energy as possible why
should i try to use less energy and
there's several answers to that question
the number one reason is energy has a
huge impact on the environment most of
the energy we produce and we'll talk
about that in a little bit has the
byproduct of emitting greenhouse gases
which are contributing to global warming
and then on top of that it has
implications to society the
infrastructure around us and it has
frankly impacts on your and your
family's pocketbooks because energy
costs money so let's first think about
the household
so this chart right over here which is
from the u.s energy information
administration says residential site
electricity consumption by end use and i
want to stress that it says electricity
consumption because electricity
consumption is not the only energy
consumption in a household depending on
where you are it might be around 50 or
60 percent of consumption but natural
gas is another major source and in some
cases even petroleum but when you look
over here the major uses of energy in a
household are air conditioning and
that's going to be especially pronounced
if you live in a hot and humid part of
the country or part of the world you
have space heating which is what most of
us associate with heaters and then you
have water heating many of y'all
probably don't appreciate when you take
those long hot showers that it took
energy to warm up that water and then
you have lighting you have appliances
after that so as you as an individual
wanted to conserve energy it makes a lot
of sense
to look at things like this
and so if you want to conserve energy at
home use less air conditioning if you
can use less heating if you can
take shorter showers or maybe not as hot
showers and showers not only have the
energy consumption from heating the
water but it also has energy consumption
that's happening at the water treatment
plant to clean your water and to process
your water that also takes energy and
right over here is a refrigerator and if
you have an older refrigerator or less
efficient refrigerator that's going to
use a lot more energy to do the same
work and once again it's not just impact
on the climate it's going to save you
and your family money by using less
energy
but as we'll see
energy consumption is not just a
phenomenon inside of the house
what we see here is u.s energy
consumption by source and sector in 2020
and this is a little bit of a complex
diagram but it's telling us a lot of
information here on the left it tells us
our sources of energy so 35 percent of
the energy in the united states comes
from petroleum then 34 percent from
natural gas then 12 from renewable
energy that would be things like wind
power or solar power then you have 10
percent from coal and 9
from nuclear and then not only does this
tell us where the energy is coming from
it's telling us how it is being used so
we could see 36 in the industrial sector
so that's all of the factories the
manufacturing that produces all of the
goods and services and raw materials
that we have in society
35 of our energy in the united states is
used for transportation moving things
around moving ourselves around but also
moving stuff around
and then 17 is residential 12 percent is
commercial so this would be things like
the energy that the shopping mall is
using or the energy that's being used in
an office building this little gray and
black box down here is interesting
because it shows the role of electricity
in this whole scheme
sometimes something like petroleum might
be directly used by say an industrial
user but sometimes that petroleum is
then used for electricity generation
which can then be used by these various
sectors similarly something like coal
could be used directly or it could be
used to produce electricity now one of
the eye-popping things that i didn't
appreciate until i saw this diagram are
the electrical system energy losses
roughly 65 percent of the energy is lost
if you have a more efficient electrical
grid or we know when to produce the
electricity so it more matches up with
the demand then we can once again
conserve energy as a society and so
that's why it's important to realize
some people think hey if i'm using
electricity or if i'm using an electric
car
that maybe has less impact on the
environment well it depends where that
electricity is coming from an electric
car actually gives us the option of not
necessarily using petroleum it gives us
the option of potentially using
renewable energy or nuclear energy but
that electricity could be coming from
things that significantly impact the
environment but when you generally look
at this it tells us that as a society we
have to think about things like
investing in public transportation so
that we conserve energy there this right
over here is a cement plant are there
ways to produce these things that are
more efficient that use less energy
and then there's regulations that might
motivate us as individuals to say
carpool or drive electric cars which
once again aren't necessarily going to
be cleaned it depends where that
electricity comes from but it gives us
the option of using renewable sources
so i'll leave you there energy
conservation is a complex topic but a
very very very important one but
hopefully this gives you a start on how
you can look at how energy is being used
in the world where it comes from and how
you can make a change both at the
personal level right over here and as a
member of our democracy at the societal
level